I'm on some adult [ __ ] you're on some
white hot mess never once
welcome to debateable the show where we
subject ourselves to stupid trivial
arguments so you don't have to morning
sex versus night sex on one hand it's
like wow I haven't even had my blueberry
waffles yet and this is happening on the
other hand the moon is up the day is
drawn to a close and you're finishing up
the day on a high note feel what I'm
saying
you know what I'm saying are we gonna
reach a resolution probably not but
let's dig in anyway morning sex versus
night sex it's debatable
[Music]
okay bedtime booty
morning sex it just makes sense that's
the slogan that I'm gonna give to it it
sets the tone for the day in such a
beautiful way that rhymed
your alarm goes off and there's someone
lying next to you and you want to get
your blood pumpin
nobody likes working out in the morning
I'm doing Trenton pants just roll over
shag get your heart rate up I love that
you're buying these certain things in
the morning for you to mentally and
physically feel oh that's what prozac is
for pop a pill culture they'll fix all
of our problems people need it I get
that if you're having sex at night
there's a lot of expectations afterwards
do I stay the night does this person
stay the night in the morning no
questions asked we gotta go after I have
sex I am like a little energizer bunny
I'll do the dishes I'll feed the cats
have an orgasm in the morning how's your
mood around 11 o'clock how is that two
o'clock feeling I got poop breath I look
like [ __ ] no one looks flawless in the
morning it does not owe you not true
but my breath oh but this go to the
bathroom take care of it do what you
gotta do we're in the kitchen maybe cups
and cheese crackers you know I mean like
appetizer we're talking appetizer foods
I'm not gonna wake up in the morning and
throw your ass from one side of the wall
to other side of all I don't think what
is the point of waking up taking a
shower eating your breakfast no listen
man all trainers get the act done and
then wow I just had sex and I'm having
bacon and eggs hello paradise my eggs
have chives on them and it tastes good
well no one is that fancy and you
[ __ ] chives cost a dollar
also when you're straight it's usually
ready for you in the morning you're
starting pretty prime not to get vulgar
oh my peepees heart so that that that
makes it right you know it's just like
I'm vomiting well you and your spouse
are gonna have a beautiful day together
every moment of the day afterwards it's
gonna be
connection if you have sex got it see
this is the fake news it ain't working
we're sick of it this is 2017 and it's a
2015 debatable anymore where you can
just scream again the thumbnail honestly
it's just like the mood so it's dark out
you're with your significant other
we got the drinks flowing I already
shaved the hoo-ha down there I'm prepped
for this moment cuddling in bed and
watching a movie let's watch Harry
Potter drink a couple glasses of wine
you usually don't finish the movie
we usually you watch the movie like what
was that about I don't know but I know
what what you look like naked if I'm
spending the night with you we better
[ __ ] before 9 a.m. and you're out
drinking and then you come home and you
feeling sloshy and weird you know like
someone has a drinking problem Kelsey
you're not making love with somebody 3
Leinenkugel's deep it's not happening
I'm sorry that is a raw gross just rude
you can [ __ ] literally it feels like
it's endless what if you like a good
snuggle at night after we [ __ ] yeah and
they could go for a while we can't start
hitting at 8:00 and we can hit it all
the way to 8 a.m. because guess what
daddy got to work at night you've never
heard of someone having a morning booty
call hey you up yet dude I'm on some
adult [ __ ] you're on some white hot mess
a hot mess I've never once you know
what's about to go down you know we're
gonna do it on the couch we're gonna do
in the kitchen next to the tomatoes
again I don't think he lies at night
there is nothing more relaxing it's like
exercise you can burn calories why are
you doing it and then just drift any
doctor will tell you you shouldn't
exercise before bed now that's day one
sup very nice day what that's what you
gotta resort to win has Muhammad Ali
in the morning he trained in the morning
perhaps talk about masturbation at the
very least is that training
what is that training what do you mean
misinformation and masturbation can be
trained to sum it all up morning sex is
the best it's valuable intimacy with
another person you know plus you start
off with a boner or a night sex is
better and there is no better feeling in
the world than having an orgasm and
falling straight to sleep if you [ __ ] in
the morning you end up like this
well-rounded adult ready to go to a
farmers market oh boy
kids look out as the Sun is rising you
are coming and you feel like one with
the universe right and I'm like when the
Sun is going down so am I
[Music]
you guys we know you guys are cute you
guys are cute trying to just watch my
style I would love to meet my match one
day in the debatable pit I want to meet
my match right here
[Music]